something absolutely sickening happened
and Republican senators are mostly
providing cover to Donald Trump over it
which is that Donald Trump claimed that
US military members who have suffered
traumatic brain injuries and concussions
have headaches that he doesn't consider
to be very serious Donald Trump
previously insisted that no one was hurt
when Iran launched missile attacks on
bases in Iraq that housed US troops back
on January 8th we covered that
extensively when it happened this is not
true 34 troops have been diagnosed with
either concussions or traumatic brain
injuries after those attacks Donald
Trump insists that nobody was hurt we
were first told well 11 people were
pulled out for concussions or brain
injuries that number has since climbed
to 30 for military service members
suffering traumatic brain injuries or
concussions and Donald Trump is just
downplaying the reports of the injuries
as headaches and that nothing is very
serious and there are some members of
the military that are absolutely furious
while there are others as well as many
Republican senators who are saying no no
I mean what Donald Trump is fine and
what he's saying here's Donald Trump
being asked about this at the World
Economic Forum in Davos Switzerland a
few days ago that after Iran retaliated
for the Soleimani strike no Americans
were injured we now know at least 11 US
service men were airlifted from Iraq can
you explain the discrepancy no I heard
that they had headaches and a couple of
other things but I would say yeah and I
can report it is not very serious very
serious they told me about it numerous
days lady it'd have to ask the prophet
of defense no I don't consider them very
serious injuries relative to other
injuries that I've seen I've seen what
Iran has done with their roadside bombs
to our troops I've seen people with no
legs and with no arms I've seen people
that were horribly horribly injured in
that area that war in fact many cases
put those bombs put there by solemn a
knee who's no longer with us
I consider them to be really bad
injuries no I do not consider that to be
bad injuries now Donald bone spurs Trump
calls traumatic brain injuries headaches
and just doesn't see them as a serious
thing now you know the fallacy of you
can always come up with something worse
like okay you could have a traumatic
brain injury and lose a leg all right
well yeah that would be worse we can
imagine something worse
but the completely lackadaisical nature
of Donald Trump brushing this off as not
serious as traumatic brain injuries can
be completely debilitating they can be
completely disabling for someone they
can lead to suicide Trump wouldn't know
about it of course
someone who figured out how to avoid
military service in Vietnam and by the
way I don't fault him for it if I were
at risk of being drafted to that
insanely pointless and misguided war I
also would have tried to get out of
serving in it but I wouldn't be going
around downplaying traumatic brain
injuries is not very serious because
somebody else had a more serious injury
at some other time does anybody in my
audience remember the George W Bush days
where if you even suggested anything but
endless unflinching support for not just
the troops but at the time it was if you
didn't support the mission in Iraq you
were called an anti-american traitor by
these right-wingers what happened to
that this guy does not care about the
men and women who serve the Soleimani
assassination was politically convenient
to Trump he thinks I mean it may be it
may not be he may be right we don't know
the follow-up effects aren't a concern
the injuries caused aren't a concern
period it's a world of Donald Trump and
in that world traumatic brain injuries
or headaches soldiers who aren't
captured and held as POWs he doesn't
prefer remember he said about John
McCain he prefers war heroes who don't
get captured PTSD happens because some
soldiers just aren't strong enough as
Donald Trump has previously said but his
bone spurs were serious and valid as a
reason to get the skip the war
altogether that many other people his
age simply didn't have a
choice about weren't able to appeal to a
wealthy doctor willing to write a note
to get Donald Trump out of serving in
Vietnam another aspect of this is that
Donald Trump also in addition to not
caring about the troops doesn't
understand brain injuries I mean we
could say even if he understood them he
still wouldn't care but Donald Trump
knows nothing about brain injuries and
how they can manifest causing depression
leading to suicide making it so someone
simply cannot work or live a normal life
this guy knows nothing and you have to
be really careful about anybody who
hangs their hat on I support the troops
back during the Iraq days supporting the
troops met supporting the war in Iraq
now as a progressive who cares about
people to me supporting the troops means
you don't send the troops in to fight
political battles for your personal
benefit or in george w bush's case
because his dad wasn't able to get it
done or whatever the case may be you
make sure that they have health care and
workforce reintegration when they come
home now support the troops under Trump
I don't even know what it means to
support the troops under Trump I think
it means support whatever it is Donald
Trump wants to do with the troops for
his political gain I don't even know if
that phrase has meaning in 2020 under
Donald Trump but disgusting and even
more disgusting that there are
Republicans who are defending what
Donald Trump said do you feel like you
just don't have enough time to become as
intellectually well-rounded as you would
like to be that they're just not enough
hours in your week for you to read all
of the books that you want to read one
of our sponsors is called blinka stand
it's an app that lets you consume an
entire nonfiction book in 15 minutes
it's only about eight bucks a month but
you can try it for free for a week and
get 25% off a subscription when you go
to blankest comm slash Pakman what
blinka studs is take thousands of
popular non-fiction books and condense
them into either text or audio that you
can read or listen to in just 15 minutes
and what you get is all of the most
important ideas and information from the
book imagine being able to listen to an
entire nonfiction book in the amount of
time it takes you to drive or walk
from work I just finished listening to
the way we eat now by bee Wilson whose
work I've recommended to you before
super interesting look at how the global
food system works and impacts the way
that we live
blink is has totally transformed how I
consume information I love it of course
I read a book in its entirety when I can
but there are simply just so many books
that I want to read and would not have
the time for if it weren't for blink
Asst they have books on politics
economics philosophy science you name it
you can try it out yourself totally free
for a week and get 25% off if you decide
to subscribe just by going to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video like the
rest of us I bet you're going into 2020
thinking about what you didn't get
around to in 2019 and your goals for the
new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you